[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce set 8
sociétés en ce mois d'octobre nous
parlerons du phénomène du bizutage dans
les week-ends d'intégration et les
soirées étudiantes sous prétexte de
partager un moment en dehors du cadre de
l'école dé de resserrer les liens entre
la communauté étudiants ils sont parfois
le lieu de nombreuses violences et
agressions
pour en parler avec nous en plateau ce
soir emmanuel piette bonjour à four vous
êtes la présidente du collectif
féministe contre le viol
en face de vous et laine le maire vous
êtes élu au conseil d'administration de
l'université versailles saint quentin
mais aussi présidente d'un terrasse
hausse bonjour mais tu dis sharana vous
êtes responsable de l'unef dans les
yvelines lunesse
l'union nationale des étudiants de
france est enfin benoît kermoal
secrétaire régional adjoint
d'ile-de-france d'unsa éducation bonjour
merci à tous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
pourtant interdite par la loi depuis
1998 le bizutage se poursuit dans les
universités et grandes écoles
alcool imposé aux participants aux jeux
dangereux violences sexuelles on ne
parle plus de bizutage mais de soirée et
de week-ends d'intégration finalement il
n'ya que le terme qui a changé
absolument les violences et les
humiliations continue à peu près avec la
même force et la lumière vous êtes élu
au conseil d'administration de
l'université versailles 50 ans deux fois
par an les responsables d'associations
étudiantes de l'uv espions des réunions
de sensibilisation à l'alcool dispensés
par avenir santé il n'y a pas de
débordements dans vos week-ends
d'intégration
non tout ce qui nous est remonté en tout
cas c'est globalement la conclusion
qu'on tire c'est que tout se passe très
bien
tout est très très bien encadrés avec
des
des commandeurs des systèmes de
prévention qui sont de mieux en mieux
rodé de chaque année alors justement une
charte a été mise en place par la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
frédéric vidal pourtant parfois non
respecté écouté marie france henry
président du comité national contre le
bizutage c'est une charte qui est très
bien faite qui devrait être signé par
tout le tout jeune qui souhaite
organiser un week end d'intégration en
particulier les bd eu malheureusement ce
n'est pas le cas est encore trop souvent
on constate que cette charte n'a pas été
proposé aux organisateurs une réaction
effectivement vous fait qu'ils aient une
charte déjà c'est quelque chose de
positif ça on ne peut pas le nier
maintenant il n'y a pas d'élément
contractuels obligatoire à cette charte
c'est à dire qu'on peut la signer et
ensuite il ya la nécessité et
éventuellement de répression
la présidente du comité contre contre le
bizutage le dit bien c'est un premier
pas mais il faut aller au delà la
nécessité comme vous l'avez dit c'est
aussi des informations de l'information
l'unsa-education appartient comme
d'autres associations à ce comité dont
il ya la nécessité de diffuser ensuite
lorsqu'il ya débordement
et lorsque il y à des faits avérés de
violence
il ya une nécessaire répression c'est
interdit par la loi
il y a donc la possibilité de dents
d'avoir une répression si nécessaire
alors parmi les responsabilités
incombant aux signataires de cette
charte figurent celles de renseigner de
façon précise le programme du week-end
d'intégration budget risques accidentels
liés aux lieux programme quantité
d'alcool prévu
les organisateurs doivent faire appel à
des secouristes
est ce que c'est le cas je me tourne
vers vous en tant que représentant de
l'union nationale des étudiants de
france
alors malheureusement ça peut des fois
être le cas mais ça ne règle pas tous
les problèmes c'est pour ça que lorsque
ma collègue du coup 10e que enfin lu vs
qu font tout se passe bien on soit on
n'a pas de témoignages donc on a pas de
faits fin qui nous sont montés parce
qu'un des problèmes aussi qu'on a c'est
que il ya une difficulté à témoigner à
dire ce qu'il s'est passé puisque déjà
c'est quelque chose de traumatisant que
ce qui peut se passer pour les victimes
donc malgré tout l'accompagnement qu'on
peut mettre en place si ces faits se
déroulent le témoignage sera difficile
donc il ya des outils comme vous l'avez
dit francky sont mises en place pour
pousser les organisations étudiantes à
accompagner les étudiants lors de ce
week-end d'intégration pour que tout se
passe bien mais malheureusement malgré
cet encadrement
il peut des fois par l'effet de groupe
par l'effet de masse se passer du coup
des actions qui peuvent du coup finir
assez tragiquement l'université
versailles saint quentin a mis en place
également un contrôle des bouteilles
lorsque les fêtes se déroulent dans
leurs locaux chaque association qui
demande une subvention pour une soirée
ou un événement
comme les week-ends d'intégration
signent un protocole alcool vous avez
trois doses réglementé vous faisiez vous
vérifier réellement lors de ces soirées
comment vous faites pour savoir que cet
étudiant et à deux ou trois doses
d'alcool s'est pas vraiment on peut dire
vérifiable parce que en soit la personne
c'est géré par le bar et ça c'est
l'organisation même qui fait par
l'association
mais par contre effectivement lu vs qq
part le protocole alcool par la
commission fsd lieu donc le fonds de
subvention aux initiatives étudiantes
régis justement les subventions qui sont
accordées aux week ends d'intégration et
c'est encadré mais après c'est toujours
la même problématique personnelle à
surveiller sauf qu'en effectivement ses
week-ends d'intégration se passe en
partie dans dans une dans une boîte et
où là effectivement le chef de bach est
là pour contrôler les deux alcools mais
comment il fait pour savoir que cet
étudiant es tu as a par exemple deuxième
dose parce que vous avez seulement trois
doses à réglementer comment comment il
fait pour vérifier ça c'est ça qui est
compliqué on va dire à contrôler et
souvent il ya des systèmes de bracelets
qui sont mis en place ou d'autres
mécanismes et je vous avoue que j'ai pas
eu le retour sur sur ça alors justement
pendant ses week-ends d'intégration il
ya parfois des débordements regardez cet
extrait pour un sens comique est monté
passion on s'est rassemblés on est
montés dans le bus dans le bus tout
buvette ou monde était mort et les
deuxièmes années bizuté les nouveaux ils
ont commencé à se passer d'aidé aux
embauches qu'ils ont changé le bo par un
god
c'était mon tour j'ai dit stop toi aussi
fait entendre ta voix
emmanuel piette quand on voit cet
extrait on peut se demander soirée
d'intégration plutôt de désintégration
de l'amour-propre absolument moi je dois
dire que j'ai fait ma formation
on reçoit beaucoup d'appels de
d'étudiants qui ont subi des agressions
lors de week-ends d'intégration qui
commence un peu comme comme cette
histoire là c'est à dire ça commence
dans le
dans le cas où on se connaît pas les
premières années sont contents de venir
parce que peut-être elle vont faire des
rencontres et où immédiatement le
pouvoir est pris et de fête et de
l'alcool on demande aux filles de donner
leur soutien gorge
et puis si tu le donnes pas à therrien
quenouille d'un pull donne et c'est des
choses comme ça qui vont faire que ça va
aller crescendo jusqu'à des agressions
sexuelles gravissime voir des vieux et
c'est pas si rare que ça on en a pas mal
de témoignages et moi ce qui m'a frappé
je reçois niasse à phanom c'est que de
ces jeunes femmes là c'est impossible à
dire tant qu'on est dans l'année de
l'agresseur ou dans l'école de
l'agresseur les locales vont finir par
le dire quand elles auront fini leur
cursus
mais ça leur a sacrément polluer la vie
c'est pour ça que c'est difficile de
dire stop ben c'est difficile de dire
stop
quand tout le monde te regarde que
finalement l'ambiance est telle que si
c'est toi qui t'y stop tu es vraiment
que la curée lanouilh et que donc tu
c'est compliqué et puis après ça va être
compliqué de parler parce que
l'agresseur il est là et puis c'est le
deuxième c'est le troisième année il a
pignon sur rue et ça va être compliqué
des mots parfois durs des mises en scène
présentée au départ comme lui dit qu'ils
évoluent vers des humiliations et des
violences et tout ça se produit lors de
moments censé resserrer les liens entre
étudiants étudiants souvent issus de
grandes écoles ou d'universités au nom
de quoi est ce qu'il y aurait sept
étapes de sélection supplémentaire pour
intégrer ces écoles pourquoi
histoire de tradition mais avec la loire
2008 1998 on a considéré qu'il fallait
supprimer cette tradition donc le
bizutage de ne doit pas exister points
oh non quoi ensuite vous l'avez dit
c'est parfois des écoles qui sont
sélectives comme dix écoles d'ingénieurs
ya aussi mais tina finir métier il ya
aussi des écoles de commerce donc
militaire et effectivement il ya cette
volonté de reproduire une forme de
tradition mais encore une fois la le
cadre légal existe il y à des
responsables que ce soient des
responsables d'universités ou alors des
chefs d'établissement quand ce sont des
classes préparatoires
ce sont les chefs d'établissements les
responsables des écoles peuvent aussi
peut être sanctionné et il faut aussi
qu'ils sanctionnent une des sanctions
lorsqu'il ya trouble c'est d'exclure les
personnes qui sont responsables de ça il
ya eu pendant un certain temps la
volonté de ne pas le voir la volonté de
considérer que ce n'était pas si grave
que ça maintenant il faut sanctionner
quand c'est nécessaire
et avant ça il ya aussi toute la
prévention on le voit dans l'extrait là
c'est souvent des choses à connotation
sexuelle parce qu déconsidère l'autre
pour des raisons sexuelle et hilal il ya
tout un travail de prévention
d'information de sensibilisation de
lutte contre les stéréotypes et ça
commence très tôt nous le voit bien dans
nos syndicats on essaie de former
ne serait-ce que les enseignants aussi
les responsables et chefs
d'établissement cette idée d' omerta
parfois et des chefs d'établissement qui
sont sensibles à l'idée de ne pas faire
de vagues et donc de ne pas dire qu'il
se passe des choses mais il ya tout un
travail en amont de prévention et il me
semble que c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important
justement des campagnes de prévention
ont été lancés de sensibilisation
écoutez marie france henry responsable
du comité national contre le bizutage
malheureusement on constate encore trop
souvent les jeunes ont peur de parler
peur des conséquences que pourrait avoir
le fait de d'annoncer leur hostilité au
bizutage
on peut parler d'omerta tout à fait
moi j'ai par exemple une époque
distribuaient des préservatifs et 7
plusieurs fois des étudiants mois plus à
mesure va y avoir un week end
d'intégration donnez nous des cas des
boîtes de préservatifs
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça quand même
et ça veut dire ça ça veut dire que le
sexe est compris dans le week end
d'intégration avec l'alcool j'imagine
cause l'alcool ils ont demandé de
l'alcool moi je distribue des
préservatifs vont me demandez pas à la
tipp et le sens de ça c'est quand même
questionnement que fait l'encadrement
scolaire dans ces cas là c'est c'est
difficile encore une fois on ne peut
considérer que certains week-ends
d'intégration se passe hors temps
éducatif
or ce n'est pas le cas puisque comme il
y a de la volonté d'intégrer on voit
bien que c'est même si c'est pas du
temps scolaire c'est quand même de la
responsabilité
donc là il ya un droit de regard
importants comme la charte il ya un
droit de contrôle aussi qui doit qui
doit être fait et puis on peut passer
par l'interdiction pour des classes
préparatoires par exemple qui sont dans
des lycées où il ya parfois des
internats parce que c'est souvent là que
ça se passe où on ne peut considérer que
l'interdît ce ensuite l'interdît pour
expliquer et il faut aussi sensibiliser
tout le monde vous l'avais dit il ya les
fêtes content c'est à dire que il ya un
effet de groupe on se tait ou on
considère que après tout c'est pas si
grave où on s'est sacrifié pour aller
dans cette école et du conseil bon bah
c'est un passage presque obligé tout
cela nécessite une formation
moi je partage son avis fin pour le coup
on peut aussi le voir que même lorsque
ben poule s'éviter une d'intégration
sont annoncés aux étudiants pendant
qu'il va y avoir des fois des
simulations de viol dans l'amphithéâtre
pendant que la personne est en train de
s'exprimer devant les étudiants au
regard de fin du corps enseignant
administratif prend acte du coup
tolèrent parce qu'il dit dans les yeux
amusés mais il peut il la préfère dire
qu'ils ne font qu il ne cumule que le
ne voit pas parce que voilà donc ça
s'est passé hors de son champ de vision
mais ça se passe c'est réel c'est des
choses qui ont encore lui aujourd'hui
dans des universités dans nos écoles
dans nos établissements en général et
malheureusement il ya une nécessité de
pédagogie pour les ordinateurs mais
aussi pour le corps administratif qu'il
laisse passer des fois passé ces actes
bien une nécessité a sanctionné par les
commissions à disciplinaire les
étudiants et les responsables de ces
événements lorsque ça se déroule mais
aussi de mettre en place des cellules
d'écouté
dans tous les cas qu'il y ait ou pas des
actes de bizutage dans les événements
parce que c'est par des cellules
d'écouté qui sont autonomes et
indépendantes des armateurs et de
l'administration qui permettent
notamment de délier la parole et de
libérer la parole des victimes pour
justement après parler de ce qui peut se
passer ça peut être des agressions
sexuelles du viol enfin et d'autres
événements est ce qu on peut aussi
remarquer c'est que c'est souvent à
cause d'une consommation excessive
d'alcool
enfin que les victimes souvent ou s'ils
ne savent pas trop france qui s'est
passé et donc si vous si c'est de donner
une assistance psychologique à ces
personnes vous parliez du viol 13% des
victimes de viols ont porté plainte
suite aux viols et tentatives de viols 1
% des plaintes conduisent à une
condamnation
quels conseils pouvez-vous donner à ces
victimes et les lumières
je sais pas si je peux donner un nom
c'est à ces victimes à par s'orienter
vers des cellules psychologiques
spécifiques par exemple y en a dans les
commissariats y en a dans les
universités lui fait est ce qu met en
place une
cellule justement psychologique
vis-à-vis d'une part l'égalité
homme-femme et d'autre part
effectivement les viols et la prévention
après j'ai aussi un témoignage un petit
peu différente parce que le fait que je
sois président de la fédération
intéresse aux excuses maintenant
contacter vraiment privilégié sur le
terrain comment ça se passe sur les way
sur les vingt associations qui composent
la fédération et le retour que j'ai
effectivement je ne sais pas tout mais
personne ne sait jamais tout mais mais à
chaque fois que des événements ont été
organisés par des associations avec la
prévention qui est fournie par
intéresser aux donc les packs soirée par
exemple de préservatifs de bouchons
d'oreilles et 2 et 2 éthylotests excusez
moi de donner des préservatifs en
prévention à quoi on peut être on pense
à tout cas d'intégration
on va forcément faire du sac soirée
c'est en général qui est une soirée un
événement festif ont un événement
jusqu'au laboratoire tout son sens on
préfère donner pour de la prévention
plutôt que après de rester devant le
fait et se dire ah bah oui si on en
avait eu bat être que j'aurais pas le
sida peut-être que j'aurais pas eu une
ist
en cas de débordement il y à des
sanctions le bizutage est un délit
depuis une loi de 1997 initiée par
ségolène royal alors ministre déléguée
chargée de l'enseignement scolaire
le bizutage est puni de six mois
d'emprisonnement et de 7500 euros
d'amendé
ces peines sont doublées si la victime
est une personne vulnérable ou mineures
est-ce qu'il faut sanctionner davantage
le viol ils ont sanctionné ces vingt ans
de toul
et puis les agressions sexuelles ses 58
ans donc s'il ya des crimes des
agressions sexuelles
et puis un délit de bizutage mais les
violences physiques aussi sont
sanctionnées en en plus de ce à dire que
ça ne se résume pas à du bizutage
s'exécuter suffisant pour vous ces taxis
on appliquer les lois
vraiment ça serait suffisant l'idée
qu'enfin moi je
quand on se promène dans
les voix les défilés d'intégration là
moi j'ai vu sa médecine récemment ils
ont une connotation sexuelle immédiate
les gars ils ont des machins des machins
pour le remplacer leur verger normes ils
miment des enculage et c'était on peut
pas penser une seconde que ça n'est pas
un million donc c'est déjà faut les
regarder ces il faut vraiment regarder
les vous les verrez si on veut bien les
regarder on les voit mais c'est ça
l'idée c'est pour l'instant on fait
comme si de rien et je crois que c'est
ça qu'on voudrait arrêter parce que je
pense qu'il faut aussi c'est de trouver
aussi des sanctions font qu'ils soient
plus encadré vie si en interne de
l'établissement sur ce que pour le coup
là c'est ce que dit le code pénal mais
le copines elles ne s'appliquent pas
forcément à dans les établissements dont
on a des fois des personnes qui sont
sanctionnés par la justice mais que
l'établissement se retrouve un peu
appauvri on va dire juridiquement pour
pouvoir réagir rapidement et faire en
sorte de mettre aussi en sécurité les
victimes donc moi comme je le disais
tout à l'heure pour le coup je pense
qu'il faudrait qu'il ait déjà une
cellule sans qu'ils soient mises en
place à la suite de ces événements pour
permettre de recueillir les témoignages
des victimes dans un cadre au safe dans
un cadre qui permette à libération de la
parole et de pouvoir aussi des fois
saisir le conseil de la commission
disciplinaire rapidement pas forcément
attendre que le président de l'unps rt
décide de la saisir parce que comme je
les dis aussi pour le coup c'est un cas
qui a ses grades et qui nécessite
d'avoir une réaction assez rapide de
l'établissement et donc il faut
permettre à ce que cette commission
disciplinaire à l'appui cette saisie la
plus facilement possible par l'étudiant
ou l'étudiante pour pouvoir être
protégés et faire en sorte que ses
agresseurs mappus du coup être
sanctionné a assez rapidement et ces
sanctions elles doivent être nécessaires
pour mettre en sécurité à la victime et
oui pour faire comprendre que ce qui est
fait n'est pas normal dans un cadre
universitaire il ya d'autres façons de
se rencontrer de se connaître de faire
groupe que d'humilier je sais juste ça
on supprimera l'humiliation dans
l'ensemble de ces dispositifs
on aurait déjà gagné quelque chose mais
c'est vraiment la tradition entre guy
c'est l'humiliation et des procès qui
dure parfois jalal a mis 24 ans de
l'école de saint cyr est mort noyé en
octobre 2012 toujours pas de jugement le
procès est reporté au 9 décembre ça va
faire maintenant sept ans sept ans de
procédure
est-ce que c'est pas ça qui décourage
les victimes tout est fait pour
décourager les victimes
les plats ne sont pas prises les
instructions sont très longues
le présumé innocent se défend il est
fait invalider toutes les pensées dur
donc ça dure très longtemps et les
victimes ont pas beaucoup d'argent pour
payer les frais d'avocats et des choses
comme ça donc c'est vrai que si les
institutions ça ne m'aide pas résolument
aux côtés des victimes
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué pour elle
une étudiante veut faire avancer les
choses une enquête nationale sur les
violences sexuelles et sexistes dans
l'enseignement supérieur a été lancé par
l'observatoire étudiants écouter la
présidente
iris maréchal objectif premier c'est
vraiment d'évaluer l'ampleur et le type
de violences sexuelles subies par les
étudiants donc pour cela on a établi un
questionnaire avec un comité d'experts
donc ce comité d'experts est composé de
psychiatres d'infirmiers de sociologues
et donc on a créé un google forme qui se
compose de trois parties
donc la première c'est des cas pratiques
pour tester les connaissances des
étudiants sur des situations
d'homophobie d'agression sexuelle et de
viol donc ça c'est tout simplement
savoir si les étudiants sont à même de
reconnaître sa situation et de savoir ce
qu'il faut faire
la deuxième partie du questionnaire
c'est une partie pour les victimes et
les témoins nommons demande aux
étudiants de nous dire si tout
simplement ils ont vu des choses ils ont
été victimes
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait et quel a été
l'impact sur la santé mentale et sur
leur scolarité tout simplement et la
dernière partie c'est une partie pour
connaître les solutions que les
étudiants aimerait que remettre en place
en tête
le questionnaire est en circulation
jusqu'à décembre l'objectif espéré deux
et dix mille réponses ce genre de
questionnaire ça peut faire évoluer
changer les choses
c'était ça fait sortir du déni là on est
en train de dire que y'en a pas
des études faites sur les étudiants au
plan national montre qu'il ya au moins
13% des jeunes qui disent avoir été
victimes d'agressions sexuelles pendant
leurs études
donc on voit bien aidé viole donc on
voit bien que il faut que ce soit
quelque part et c'est pas répartie
particulièrement homogène mans france
préfère un petit tour de table à ce
sujet plus d'efforts pour pour le sujet
défendre moi je pense que déjà pour le
confort il y à des fins qui se passe et
que donc il faut permettre de libérer la
parole par ces questionnaires même si
que je pense que dans certains côtés
lorsqu'on l'a des associations
représentatives qui organise ce genre
d'événement qui disent avoir signer une
une charte et donc ne pas pouvoir
organiser fin de bizutage au sens de
leur événement ça contredit aussi la
version de la victime qui a subi les
chocs d'une certaine manière et qui
bloque aussi la facilité de pouvoir du
coup témoigner sans on
on le voit au quotidien que lorsqu'on a
des des assauts nationale fin qui du
coup lens des procédures en fin de
charte nationale qui sont signés ce
n'est pas forcément respectée
et en plus de cela face à bah ça rentre
en contradiction avec les faits des
victimes mais je pense qu'il ya aussi un
autre enfin à notre sujet c'est aussi
qu'au delà des faits de viol ou
d'agression sexuelle il ya aussi toutes
les autres violence de discrimination
que peuvent aussi subir ses étudiants
comme des actes racistes
franck antisémites islamophobes
homophobes et tout ce qui peut aussi
être mises en place et ça on le voit
tous les ans adam levy quête
d'intégration car on est dans une
société où va être du coup on a des
individus qui ne sont pas forcément
enfin formé sur la question de la lutte
contre les discriminations et qui du
coup peuvent avoir des comportements
sexistes et être des discriminant avec
leurs camarades venus à carmaux à
l'unsa-education une petite réaction
je pense qu'il faut distinguer plusieurs
choses il y a d'une part la nécessité
lorsqu'il ya des faits donc délictueux
de déposer plainte
je pense que l'art
à cette nécessité là une plainte qui est
parfois difficile
on l'a dit parce que on est dans un
contexte où justement on se sent parfois
encore plus victimes dans cet élément là
ensuite il ya l'accompagnement aussi ça
peut être par des témoignages dont qui
sont des témoignages on va dire anonyme
et là c'est du coup aux responsables de
chaque école ou d'universités de mettre
en place des dispositifs
je crois que les deux sont liés et
parfois s'il ya un flou et ce type de
questionnaire est aussi un élément mais
s'il ya un flou c'est que on ne va pas
jusqu'au dépôt de plainte et du coup il
peut y avoir le sentiment que ça
n'existe pas que c'est harry etc etc
il ya les deux choses nécessaires et il
ya un troisième volet important c'est le
volet de la prévention
lorsque vous évoquez la lutte contre les
discriminations le fait que c'est aussi
synonyme de domination masculine très
souvent dans cet élément là tous les
jeunes femmes sont plus touchées
bien sûr et puis il ya cette manifestion
ce de la sexualité dans ce type de
compte en comportement ça ça ça
nécessite de travailler sur les
stéréotypes sa décennie de la prévention
et il ya un dernier élément c'est l'idée
aussi qu'on ne peut pas rester témoin
sans rien faire c'est aussi l'idée que
cette omerta cnooc on soit c'est parce
que des témoins se taisent alors ça peut
être des témoins étudiants ou lycéens
quand ils sont classes préparatoires
mais ça peut être aussi des responsables
administratifs des enseignants des chefs
d'établissement tout le monde a à jouer
un rôle
à mon avis à ce niveau là pour conclure
et laine le maire en tant que
responsable d'une association est
également élu au conseil
d'administration de l'université
je suis d'accord avec ce qui a été dit
ce genre de questionnaire ça permet de
prendre conscience des fois et aussi de
sortir du déni c'est ce qu'ils essayent
de mettre en place aujourd'hui
l'université intéresse aux uvs qu
vis-à-vis d'une conférence qui va se
dérouler le 25 novembre prochain qui va
permettre aux étudiants d'assister à une
conférence et ensuite un débat groupe et
sur le thème des violences sexuelles
faites aux femmes
ce genre de conférences mais aussi de
tables rondes qui seront organisées
prochainement qui permettent aux
étudiants de discuter entre eux en un
cadre plus restreint et de briser un
petit peu les tableaux pour l'instant
les événements étudiants les week-ends
d'intégration se sont toujours bien
passé on n'a pas eu de retour là dessus
par contre par le commissariat de police
de montigny-le-bretonneux on a eu des
retours sur juste des regroupements
d'étudiants qui ont conduit à
effectivement trois viols et agressions
sexuelles
merci merci à tous d'avoir participé à
sept huit sociétés ce questionnaire mené
par l'observatoire étudiants se clôture
donc en décembre les réponses seront
remontés aux députés notamment à marlène
schiappa merci à tous et la fin de ce
sept huit sociétés très belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]